transylvania
the name conjures it all dense pine
and passable craggy cliffs thick ground
fog
this is the mythic forest of your
childhood nightmare
bran castle billed as the last standing
relic of a man some call
dracula
the story goes that romania's bottomless
well of tyranny catastrophe and overall
human misery can all be traced back to
one terrifying ruler
and his supernatural evil
vlad the third basarab better known as
vlad impaler
he was nicknamed dracula which means the
son of the devil
ah okay so have you ever heard of um
the curse of vlad tepes yeah
he lost his wife he lost his dynasty he
lost his family
and he signed the document in order to
bring a curse down
against his enemy and he promised that
he will return
that was his curse and i will take
revenge against those that they betrayed
me
he was killed and his body was buried in
the monastery nearby bucharest
later on when they opened the coffin
they never found his body
which is quite creepy yeah right
you do start to wonder what if he's
coming back again
so you'd be worried if you were his
enemy you might be nervous
yeah yeah vlad spent much of his life
constructing a fearsome persona
in some ways his reputation was so
extreme
that it haunts the entire world so one
of his tactics was to
capture prisoners and then impel them
it's a wooden stick that goes into the
rectum
gross uh they pull you up and you stay
alive like three days
oh my god three days that really
terrified
his enemy the turks yeah
what are some of the other ways you
would do it well setting a fire
or poisoning wells one
a very bad one he captured a family
like brothers and he boiled one of them
and then he forced the rest of the
family to eat
him he sounds like a really nice guy
when you have your enemy at the gate all
the time you don't have time to make
people love you
yeah fascists always say that
once he took power in 1448 vlad began a
lifelong battle to protect his country
from invaders from all sides
hungarians rival nobles but most of all
the ever expanding ruthless ottoman
empire
vlad's mortal enemy
the other kings and rulers of his time
had surrendered and they all paid
tribute
but vlad fought on with the sheer hatred
that defies description
perhaps because the ottomans had
kidnapped him as a child
and by the time his father and brother
were killed
his hatred had grown so virulent that we
still make tv shows about him
600 years later
vlad himself he was right here yeah
right here
he touched these walls amazing
he used to capture rats and birds take
the skin off
and then impale them in a small wooden
stick wow
[Music]
you know 600 years ago there was a real
person
here glad the impaler
looked at his little window
thought about revenge
[Music]
you